perché allora rimettetela capisce da
quando la finite perché mamma mamma
importante la carta igienica che fino
[Musica]
adesso come faccio a mali estremi
giusto il tempo per uomini e donne
[Musica]
no ma io esco business tanto unica punta
marina
se non ti piace cambia canale no no no
va benissimo del giornale io adoro il
telegiornale è un notebook informati su
ciò che succede
[Musica]
mi è venuto languorino vediamo cosa
offre la casa maronna che fame marina
haifa menti prepara qualcosa
no no no no grazie non si disturbi o già
mangiato prima di venire qui grazie mi
mangerei tutta la casa punto è compreso
[Musica]
ma cos'è sta roba forte farhadi ha il
mangiare insalata porto via parmigiano e
una bomba dai marina è con i suoi atene
diversa buonissima la verza io adoro è
il mio piatto preferito
[Musica]
basta così va benissimo mi sta
sicuramente mamma al riscaldamento che
sto girando per il freddo per caso no no
no no perché lo teniamo rispetta 20
massima se vuoi versiamo non c'è
problema storto benissimo temperatura
perfetta i tirchi
[Musica]
marina ecco la tua acqua grazie
gentilissimo molto gustosa
[Musica]
[Applauso]